[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY GALLO: Thank
you for having me.
And thank you so
much for everyone,
for making the time, both in
the room and on the livestream.
So as Rachel said,
this is my book.
I wrote it.
It came out, actually, the
same day as Rachel's book.
Our books are twins, I
like to think of them.
And I'm going to tell
you about the book,
main concepts in the book.
But before I do that, I want
you all to do something.
I want you all to think.
Think about the time that you
had a conflict with someone.
Maybe it was at work.
Maybe it was your boss.
Maybe it was your
parent, or your spouse,
or your teenage kid.
And maybe it was this
morning, or maybe it
was last week or
maybe last month.
Now I want you to
think about how
that conflict made you feel.
And I want people to shout
out just the one word.
What's the one word that
describes how you felt?
AUDIENCE: Stressed, frustrated.
AMY GALLO: Stressed, frustrated.
AUDIENCE: Unheard.
AMY GALLO: Unheard.
Irate.
Did I hear that right?
AUDIENCE: Angry.
AMY GALLO: Angry.
OK, I tried to beautify
it up a little bit, irate.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Dismissed.
AMY GALLO: Dismissed.
AUDIENCE: Sad.
AMY GALLO: Sad.
I did this talk once and
someone said strangled.
And I was really concerned
about how they handled conflict
at their organization.
What I've never heard when
I've asked people to do this
is energized, excited,
invigorated, respected.
And that's because this is the
natural human response when
we get into a conflict.
Conflict is when we feel
threatened, our identity,
our resources, our needs.
We're having needs and
wants that aren't being met.
And we have a natural
of stress response.
So we end up having
our heart rate go up,
we have higher levels of stress.
We lose access to the
prefrontal cortex.
We go into what Dan Goleman
calls amygdala hijack.
And we're just not making
good, rational decisions.
Now I believe that it
doesn't have to be that way.
I believe that organizations
should and need
to have disagreements
and conflicts,
but most often,
they're handled in ways
that are unprofessional
and unproductive.
And that's because we don't
have the skills to have
productive disagreements.
And more importantly,
we've gotten to this place,
both in our organizations,
but in our country,
certainly, at large, that
disagreement actually
equals unkindness.
And this is something
that's really
detrimental to
human interaction.
So I'm on a personal mission.
Why I wrote this
book is that I want
people to think of
conflict and disagreement
as a normal, healthy,
productive part of interacting
with other human beings.
And when we disagree
with compassion, empathy,
and kindness, it has lots
of positive benefits.
But unfortunately,
what's happening
is the exact opposite.
People are becoming
meaner to each other.
This is a chart that
comes from Chris Porath.
She wrote a book called,
"Mastering Civility."
I highly recommend it.
She studies uncivil
behavior at work.
What she's seen is that over
the last 20 or so years,
people are reporting more
and more rudeness at work.
So this is a number
of people who
report someone being rude
to them at work in the last,
at least once, in
the last month.
So we're getting
meaner to each other.
And this has its costs.
A 2008 study done by CPP,
which is the people who
create the Myers-Briggs
test, a study that
showed that on average we're
spending 2.8 hours a week
dealing with conflict at work.
Now that's a lot of time.
And I imagine, since the study
was done, about 10 years ago,
that it's actually gotten worse.
And that same study equated
this with $359 billion
in paid hours.
It's even worse if
you're a manager.
A study by the American
Management Association
showed that the average
manager is spending 18 to 26%
of their time.
Now full disclosure, this
was a study done in 1976.
This is the study that's
most cited around how much
managerial time.
I would posit that we
actually spend even more.
And I've seen more
recent surveys
that show some managers
report spending up
to 40% of their time
dealing with conflicts.
This also leads to
performance issues.
So 65%, a study by the
Penn Behavioral Corporation
found that 65% of problems,
performance problems,
are linked to strained
relationships.
So it's most often what's
happening between people
that's causing these problems.
So we're being mean to each
other, It's taking up our time,
it's costing us
money, it's leading
to performance problems.
What are we to do?
Now first and foremost,
we have to embrace
conflict as not a negative.
If you said to me I work
in a conflict free office.
I would say that
sounds pleasant,
but probably not
very productive.
So we have to embrace conflict
as a normal, healthy part
of organizations.
Now all of these stats that
I've just reported show that--
have led to what Bill
Fisher and William
Ury, who wrote "Getting to Yes,"
they're the Harvard Negotiation
project, said conflict
is a growth industry.
This is a quote from their book.
Now this is great news for
me as a conflict expert.
This is bad news for
the rest of the world.
So what we need to
think about is, first,
like I said, embrace conflict
as a normal, healthy part
of interacting with people.
And think about the
positive outcomes
that come from conflict.
First and foremost, more
successful work outcomes.
If I see a project one way,
and you see it another,
and we have to discuss our
different opinions to come
to a solution, chances
are the work outcome
is going to be better.
If marketing is
pushing for one thing,
and sales is for another,
that natural tension
in organizations is going to
make the end product better,
even if it's slightly
uncomfortable, or very
uncomfortable for the
people in the process.
Second of all, you
have the opportunities
to learn and grow.
The more that you are forced
to think about your position,
to articulate why you
disagree, what your points are,
the more you're going to learn
about what's important to you,
the more you're going
to expand as a person.
Third, you're going have
improved relationships.
Now I have a
10-year-old daughter.
She understands
this intuitively.
She came back from a sleepover
a few weekends ago and told me,
she had the best time.
And I said, great, why did
you have the best time.
She said Sophie and I
fought the entire night.
We fought about
what movie we were
going to watch, we fought about
what time we should go to bed,
where we were going to sleep.
I said that doesn't
actually sound that fun.
She said, no, but
now, we're back BFFs.
So she understood when you
go through a tough situation
with someone, when you have
to do all that negotiation,
you end up having
a stronger bond.
And the research shows this
is true at work as well.
And lastly, that leads to
the last positive outcome
that I'm going to talk about,
which is job satisfaction.
So if you feel like you can
disagree with your colleagues,
if you're not walking
on eggshells, worried
that a disagreement
is going to come up,
you're much more
satisfied at work.
Now how do we get these
positive outcomes?
That's what my book does.
It takes research from
neuroscience, emotional
intelligence experts,
management science,
and makes, sort of
boils it down to a very
practical,
straightforward approach
into how to handle conflict.
So what I want to share
with you today from the book
are some tools and concepts
that will hopefully
make conflict less
stressful for you
and help you reap these
positive outcomes that I just
talked about.
And that's because
dealing with conflict
is an essential skill in
today's organizations.
Just chatting with a few
of you at the beginning
here before we got
started, it's clear
you all know that there are
conflicts on the horizon
or that you're
experiencing conflicts.
In order to function in
today's organizations,
you must have these skills.
So the first concept I
want to talk to you about
is that most of us self-select
into one of two categories.
We either tend to avoid
conflict or we tend to seek it.
So avoiders, that's
exactly how it sounds.
Avoiders are people who probably
want to hide under the desk
when a disagreement comes up,
they really value harmony.
They value relationships.
Anytime things get tense, they
want to back away or placate.
They want things to go smoothly.
Seekers, on the other
hand, are people
who really lean into
conflict when it comes up.
They're the ones whose
body language is perhaps
a little more aggressive when
things happen in a meeting,
or in the hallway with someone.
And oftentimes, they care most
about directness and honesty.
Now I self-select as a seeker.
I was the kid on the playground
that when a fight erupted,
I would scream "fight," and try
to get as many people to come
observe what was
happening, partly
because I knew that I could
then broker the disagreement
and see if we could
get to a solution.
But also because I find
uncomfortable situations
and fights really interesting.
I don't know if anyone's been
listening to the new Esther
Perel podcast.
She's a couples therapist.
So she's doing-- she
somehow got couples
to do live or recorded
therapy sessions with her.
My husband and I tried to
listen to this together.
And my husband, who is
an avoider at his core,
was so uncomfortable.
He was like, how can
you listen to this.
I was like this is fascinating.
I couldn't get enough of it.
I highly, highly recommend it.
Even if you're an
avoider, it would
help you maybe do a little
bit of aversion therapy there.
So quick question-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is
the podcast called?
AMY GALLO: It's called,
"Where Should We Begin?"
And it's actually, I think
it's just an audible now.
It should be on iTunes soon.
But so I just want
to get a quick survey
in the room of how many
avoiders and seekers.
How many people think
they're avoiders?
I would say about half the room.
And how many people
think they're seekers?
About half.
And how many think they're both?
Or neither?
So it's of course normal
that we would sometimes
seek and sometimes avoid.
You might be an
avoider with your boss
and a seeker with your mother.
You might be an avoider
with your friends,
but a seeker at work.
And that's what you want,
that's what you want to do,
is be able to figure
out when which
style is going to work for you,
and understand your default
style.
So if you have a style
that you tend to avoid,
and every time a
conflict comes up,
you're hiding under the
table, you have to think about
how can I compensate
for that, how
can I make this a little
bit more palatable for me.
Or if you tend to seek, and you
notice that people around you
are leaving the room, or
scared to interact with you,
then you need to figure out
how do I compensate for that.
Now in order to have a
rational approach to conflict,
to make those good choices,
to know what your style is
and to compensate
it, it really helps
to put a little bit of distance
between you and the situation.
And to get out of what
I was describing before
as amygdala hijack, where
you don't have access
to your prefrontal cortex.
In order to do that,
what I recommend,
and what a lot of
the book is about,
is how to analyze each
conflict that you're in.
So you want to take--
there's four steps that
I describe in the book.
Number one you want to
understand your counterpart.
Now, we are naturally
narcissistic.
And when we feel
threatened, we think
about how we are suffering.
We think about what's
happening to us,
what's our perspective
on the situation.
It is incredibly helpful to
think about the other person.
What is it that
they're going through?
Are they a seeker or an avoider?
What could be causing
this behavior?
Second, you want to identify
the type of conflict.
I talk to people about
conflict all the time.
When people find out
I wrote this book,
they want to tell me
about every fight they've
had at work in the last week.
Most people assume that
the conflict they're in
is a relationship
conflict, meaning
that it's a personal
issue between two people.
They feel disrespected,
or someone
has said something snarky.
But most conflicts
at work actually
start as one of
three other types.
And I'll go over these.
Like I said, most of us assume
that there's a relationship
conflict going on.
But more often than
not, it actually
starts as a task conflict.
So this is a disagreement
over the goal
of a project or the objective,
what you're trying to achieve.
So I think the goal of a
project is to increase revenue,
you think it is to improve
customer satisfaction.
The second, is process.
So you we may agree that the
goal is to increase revenue.
But I think we should
do that by rolling out
to our entire group of
markets at one time.
You think we should
pilot it first.
So it's a disagreement
over the how we're actually
going to get there.
And then last, there's
conflicts over status or power,
who gets to make the call.
And this is extremely common
in flat organizations,
where there's teams that
are shaping and reshaping
all the time.
Now of course,
conflicts rarely fall
into one discrete category.
More often than not,
they're actually
a combination of these things.
And what I see most
often is something
that starts as task
or process, quickly
devolves into a
personal conflict.
So you and I are
disagreeing over what
the goal of the project is.
I start sending you
late-night snarky emails
and it quickly becomes
a personal issue
Now the third step--
so when you enter a conflict
you want to ask yourself,
what type of conflict
are you having.
That is an important
step, because once
you know that you
can begin to dig
into how to actually solve it.
Because if you assume
it's a personal conflict,
those are the hardest
conflicts to actually resolve.
But if you can actually
solve the task or the process
conflict, the personal
stuff is going
to be much more easy to resolve.
So now the third step is
to determine your goal.
And I like to say if your
goal in the situation
is to prove your counterpart
wrong, find another goal.
Now that might feel
good in the near term.
It might feel good to say I
was right in this situation
and you were wrong.
Or what I hear most
often these days
is his behavior
was unacceptable,
and until he accepts his
behavior is unacceptable,
we can't move on.
If your goal is just to
prove someone's behavior is
unacceptable, you're not
going to solve that conflict,
because no one wants to
admit that their behavior was
unacceptable.
If you can actually
decide, OK, my goal here
is to save this
relationship, or my goal
is to get this project
done as quickly as possible
so I never have to
work with this person
again, that's a
goal that's going
to help serve you much better.
And that's a goal you're
going to be able to achieve.
And that will lead
to the fourth step,
which is to pick your option.
Now in most US companies
that I talk to,
they think of having a
discussion about conflict
as sitting down and
hashing things out.
And that's the direct approach.
But you actually have
several other options
for handling the conflict.
And you use them all the
time and may not even know.
So number one, you
can do nothing.
We do this all the time.
Jean Brett, who runs
the Dispute Resolution
Center at Northwestern
University,
calls this lumping it.
And we do this.
You get the snarky email, or
someone raises their voice
in a meeting, or
someone says something
that's completely off base
and undermines your authority,
and you just sort of
ignore it and move on.
And it's a great option.
It's a great
option, particularly
if you don't have much
power in the situation,
if you're dealing with
someone who's unreasonable,
or if you realize
making a big deal of it
is going to make things worse
rather than just move on.
Now there's a caveat about
the do nothing option.
If you are an avoider,
and you're like,
oh, I love the do nothing
option, I do that all the time,
you need to check yourself,
because you're likely doing it
because you're afraid to
have some conversations,
some difficult conversations.
The other caveat
is doing nothing,
then going back to your desk
and stewing, and not getting
your work done, and gossiping
with another friend about how
awful that person is, is not
doing nothing, that's actually
doing something.
So in order to
exercise this option,
you really have to be willing to
let it go, and truly let it go.
Now of course you might try
to do nothing and realize
it's not working.
You're losing
sleep, you're having
the conversation in your
head on the car ride home.
But that's OK, you can then move
to one of the other options.
There's no harm in that.
Another option is to
address it indirectly.
I often talk to
organizations, particularly I
notice in financial service
organizations, I bring this up,
and they're like,
oh, yeah, that's
the passive aggressive option.
That's where you try to get
your needs met without actually
having to talk about it.
But this is a
perfectly good option
in situations where addressing
it directly-- again, maybe
you're dealing with
someone who's unreasonable,
or with an extreme
conflict avoider,
so talking to a third
party who can maybe
intervene on your behalf
is completely appropriate.
This is also inappropriate
option in cultures
where saving face
is really important.
In a previous career as a
management consultant when
I was staffed on
a project in Korea
for four months with
this Korean conglomerate.
We had three different work
streams for the project.
And at one point we
came to an impasse
with our Korean counterparts,
where they said,
OK, we really need to figure
out which of these three work
streams we're going
to prioritize.
Things got really
heated, really tense.
And finally, they said we're
going to meet with the, CEO
and the CEO is going to help
us decide which of these we
should prioritize.
Me and my American
counterparts are like great,
let's get in the room,
let's hash it out,
we know what we
think should happen,
they know what they
think should happen.
We're going to be able to
sort this all out together.
We get in the room,
and the CEO starts
telling this long story about
the founding of the company.
And why it was all about
the people, and his family,
and providing for the
people who worked there.
And after about 20
minutes-- of course,
we're listening to all
this through an interpreter
and looking at the
interpreter sort of confused
like this is really
what he's saying?
Weren't we going to
decide which work
stream we're going to focus on?
After about 20 minutes,
he ends the story,
and everyone gets up, and
the meeting seems to be over,
and we walk out.
And my American counterparts and
I are standing around saying,
like what just happened?
And our Korean counterparts
are like did you not hear?
He told us we're prioritizing
the HR work stream, because it
was all about people.
And he had used the
metaphor and the story
of the founding of the company
to put us in a direction,
without ever having to discuss
the conflict we were having.
And that was a very
appropriate way
to solve the conflict
in that organization.
And it worked.
Because we had the
direction we needed
and we were able
to move forward.
And again, I've seen people
do this very skillfully, where
they will have a
conflict with someone,
and rather say we're
having a conflict,
let's discuss what's
going on, they'll
say I once had a previous job
with someone where we weren't
getting along, and I did
this, and he did this,
and in it's sort of just
dropping hints of this
may be a way we can move forward
without directly addressing
what's happening.
Third is address it directly.
We'll talk a lot about that
in the rest of the talk,
about how to
actually prepare for
those difficult conversations,
and how to have them.
And the fourth option is
to exit the relationship.
Now, this is what I call
the last resort option.
Very difficult to do
in most organizations.
Often hard to get a new boss.
Often hard to get
a new teammate.
So really this is a last resort.
If you've tried the other three
options, and it's not working,
you may need to
find a way to stop
interacting with this person.
I talked to someone whose story
is featured in the book, who
eventually went, after a
really difficult situation
with her boss,
eventually went to HR
and was able to sell HR
on getting her to report
to someone else, without
actually having to lay out
everything that was going on.
So it takes a lot of skill
in most organizations
to make this happen.
But I like to lay
it out as an option.
So those are the four steps
to analyze a conflict.
And this, again, the
point is, to help
you put distance
between your reaction
to the situation,
which is likely
going to be narcissistic and
emotional, and your action.
So the idea is to give
yourself some space before you
decide exactly what to do.
Now, I'm talking about this
as if you have all the time
in the world, as if you can say,
oh, you just sent me an email,
I'm going to take a half an hour
to go through these four steps.
More likely, you'll need
to buy yourself some time.
And in time pressured,
fast moving organizations
this can be difficult,
and I acknowledge that.
But there are ways that you
can give yourself a little bit
of space to do this work.
Eventually, you'll be able to do
those four steps really quickly
in your brain.
It won't take a half an hour,
sitting down, opening my book,
and looking through each step.
But in the moment,
and when you're first
getting used to this, you really
want to take the time you need.
So first, if someone is yelling,
if things are really heated,
it is OK to walk away.
What you need to do is actually
own the need to do that.
So you never want to say,
you're being unreasonable,
or you're screaming, I'm
going to take five minutes.
People do not like to be
assigned emotions or reactions.
Instead own it I need a few
minutes to think this through,
or I really need
to calm down, can I
come back to you tomorrow, or
can I send you an email later.
You can ask for a break.
So even if you've
started the discussion,
and then you realize I'm
not being rational here,
or he's not being rational
here, you can say,
you know what, again,
can I take five minutes,
and come back to you, or can we
take a walk around the building
and talk about this later.
Find a way to give yourself
the space you need.
And then lastly, don't hit send.
I cannot tell you how many times
an email completely implodes
a conflict situation.
We cannot read tone on email.
There's amazing
studies about this.
We cannot read tone.
We assume the worst intention.
When we send an
email, we assume we're
being completely clear,
transparent, and benevolent.
When we receive an
email, we assume
people are being completely
unclear and rude.
So email is a horrible
place to have a discussion
or a tense conversation.
So especially if you've written
a really long email in response
to someone who has sent you
something that you are not
happy about, don't hit send.
Delete the draft.
Put it into a document.
Save it for later.
Allow yourself to
vent, but really
make sure that you're
not engaging over email.
Now, how to prepare
for the conversation--
so once you've decided, OK,
we are going to sit down,
I need to talk to this person,
I need to stop by their desk,
how do you actually get ready?
I talk about three different
types of preparation, mental,
strategic, and logistic.
So first, mentally, if you
are going into a conversation
that you think is going to be
difficult and uncomfortable,
guess what, it is going to be
difficult and uncomfortable.
So you have to
change your mindset.
Think about if I went
into this conversation
with a positive attitude,
with thinking about something
I could learn,
what am I actually
curious about, what don't I
know about my counterpart's
perspective, or the
assumptions that she's
made that I can learn
in this conversation.
Instead of thinking about I have
to give this teammate of mine
this really negative
feedback, think
about I'm really doing tough
work to help my teammate grow.
Really put a positive frame.
And this is not sugarcoating.
This is not-- it should be
a genuinely positive take
on the situation.
But it helps so much to go into
a conversation with a much more
curious, open attitude.
Because you're going to project
that to the other person.
And so much about
resolving conflict
is about the energy you both
bring to the conversation.
If you come in, slumped
shoulders, really
nervous about what's
happening, fidgeting,
that's going to cue the person,
because of our natural instinct
to mirror another person's
behavior, that's going
to cause them to do the same.
Second, you want to take your
counterpart's perspective.
So hopefully, you've done this
when you analyzed the conflict.
But also think more deeply.
What is it that is
motivating this person?
What could explain the way
that they've reacted so far?
And granted, sometimes
you might want to be well,
he's just a passive
aggressive jerk.
If you come up with
that explanation,
try to come up with three more.
Could it be that he's
under extreme pressure?
Is she afraid of losing her job?
Is there something going on
in this person's personal life
that would better
explain what's happening?
Lastly, you want to vent
so find your most trusted
colleague, a friend
outside the organization,
and just get it all out.
Because if you have all of those
negative thoughts and feelings
about this person,
about the situation,
and you bring them
into the conversation,
again, you're going to really
make things uncomfortable
and you're going to set
yourself up for failure.
So instead, if you
can get that all out,
say it to the person,
this trusted person,
then you'll be much more
calm and collected when
you go into the discussion.
Now strategically,
how do you get ready?
One, you want to
plan your message.
So think about what you'll
say and what you won't say.
What will be helpful
to the conversation?
And what will be likely
to tick the person off?
You don't have to write it out.
You don't have to know exactly
everything you're going to say.
Because remember, you're in
conversation with another
person, you cannot
predict how they'll react.
But have a good sense of the
main points you want to make.
And jot those down,
have them ready.
Trust me, if someone comes into
a tense conversation looking
prepared, I am
nothing but grateful.
No one's going to say, you
wrote your main points down?
It's incredibly helpful to
have those at your ready,
especially if things
start to get emotional.
You also want to prepare
for multiple scenarios.
So think about what
happens if I start
to cry, what happens if he gets
up and walks out of the room.
What happens if
we get interrupted
and we only have 10 minutes
to have this conversation,
how will I react.
And the goal, again,
is not to map out
everything you'll say and
do in those situations.
But it's to make sure
that you feel prepared,
and that you don't
get blindsided.
So when something
happens, you think,
OK, I thought something
similar like this through,
and I'm ready, I'm ready for
this unforeseen situation.
Now logistically, where and
when you have this conversation
really matters.
And people often ask me, how
soon after an incident do
I want to have the conversation?
And what I always say
is as soon as possible,
but when you're both
ready to have it.
So you don't want to push
forward a conversation
if you're not
feeling like you've
done the right work, that you're
not in a good frame of mind.
If you go into the
conversation feeling hyped up,
uncomfortable, again, it's not
going to set the right tone.
So choose a time
after you've had time
to calm down, make sure you
have more than enough time
to have that discussion,
and then also choose
a good place to have it.
I often say,
especially if there's
a status conflict going
on, that you want to not
be on anyone's territory.
Go outside.
Take a walk.
If you're dealing with a
seeker, half the conversation
in a public place, where they'll
be on their best behavior,
less likely to yell.
If you know you're
a seeker, and you
think that the comfort
of a conference room
is going to make you misbehave,
take yourself outside.
Ask the person to meet
you in a neutral spot.
So once you've gotten
ready, let's talk
about how you actually have
a productive conversation
once you're in the
room, or on the phone,
or however you're having
this conversation.
First you want to
frame your message.
So there's three things you
do to frame your message.
One, you talk about a shared
goal that you both have,
something that you
have in common.
So you might say
we both really care
about getting this
project on time,
or we both really care that
this project comes under budget,
whatever shared goal you
have, or we both really care
about what's best for the team.
Second, you want to identify
the type of conflict.
So you don't have to use the
words task, process, status.
But make sure it's
clear that this is not
about personal issues.
Talk about what's the underlying
business cause or business
issue that's happening there.
And that will help
depersonalize the discussion.
And then third, you
want to ask that person,
well you want to set a
collaborative intent.
You want to make sure the
person knows that you're there
not to prove your point,
not to prove them wrong,
but to actually work
it out together.
So you might say I'm
really excited we're
having this conversation,
because success
in this situation is going to
depend on us working together.
Or you might do what Adam
Galinsky at Columbia University
has found really works in a
of these situations, which
is to ask for advice.
That will show that you're
being collaborative.
So it sounds a
little bit like this.
You might say, we
both really care
about getting this
project done on time.
I think what's really at issue
is a process conflict about how
we actually solve it.
I'd love to get your
advice on how we
can work this through together.
And that really enlists
the other person.
It shows them I'm not here
to just prove my point,
but I'm here to work
collaboratively with you.
Second, you want to
manage your emotions.
As I mentioned, we have
a natural human instinct
to want to mirror another
person's behavior.
So if you're getting
red in the face,
if your heart rate is
rising, your breathing
is getting faster,
the other person
is going to likely
react in the same way.
So what you want to do is use a
lot of mindfulness techniques.
Focus on your breathing.
Try to imagine that
you're a fly on the wall
and you're just observing
the conversation
and what's happening.
Or really narrate to
yourself in your head.
Try to give yourself some
distance from those emotions,
and narrate in your
head what's happening.
That will take you out of your
body reaction and the stress
response, and really
ground you in being there
and being present.
You can also use what a lot
of mindfulness experts--
Leah Weiss at Stanford has done
a lot of interesting research
about this, which
is called anchoring.
And it's trying to ground
yourself in your body.
So you're either
focusing on your feet
touching the ground, your
hand on the table, anything,
again, to get yourself
present in your body
and out of the rumination
going on in your brain.
Now your main job in any
difficult conversation
is to listen.
And this is not because you're
being altruistic or generous
to your counterpart.
This is because it is strategic.
The more information you
have about what the person's
interests are and what they
want out of the situation,
the more likely
you're going to be
able to propose a
solution that meets both
your needs and their needs.
So you want to ask
a lot of questions.
Ask what made you think that?
What are the assumptions
going into that?
Tell me more.
Tell me more is a fantastic
phrase, especially when someone
says something that
you immediately
want to react to negatively,
and say that's not true,
that's inappropriate.
Try saying tell me more
instead, because you're
going to find out a
lot more information,
rather than shutting
the conversation down.
And lastly, you also want to
make your viewpoint heard.
The avoiders of the world will
spend a lot of time listening,
if they've even managed
to stay in the room.
But you also want to
make sure that you
get your viewpoint heard.
And you might say to someone,
I really hear your perspective,
repeat back what they
hear, but then say,
I would like to tell you
my take on this situation.
Help transition that you've
gone from listening mode
to talking mode.
Help them understand you're
about to make your point.
And it's important.
Sometimes we assume people
understand what our interests
or needs are in a situation.
And very often they don't.
So making your viewpoint
heard, make sure
that your interests
are on the table.
Now in the process of doing all
this, sometimes, even actually
in the process of
analyzing the conflict,
sometimes a natural
resolution just
sort of evolves in
the conversation.
And you'll notice a resolution
because it has three hallmarks.
Number one, it
satisfies interests.
So it satisfies as many
interests as possible.
It has to meet some of yours
and some of your counterpart's.
It doesn't have to
meet all of them.
But for it to be a resolution
that's going to stick,
that's going to keep
the relationship intact,
it has to meet at least
some of each of yours.
Second it has to be
fair and reasonable.
Now what's fair to one person
and reasonable to another
is very different, those
are very subjective terms.
So you might think about
how would this be observed,
or how would this be
interpreted by other people.
So if we had to write this
agreement, the disagreement
that happened, the
resolution we came to,
and we had as distribute
it to everyone on our team
or our organization, would
everyone look and say, wow,
Amy really got the
deal in that situation.
Or would they think, oh,
that's fair and reasonable?
And you might even
invoke those words
in your discussion
of a resolution.
You might say, I understand
why you're proposing that,
but I can't imagine having
to pitch that to my boss.
I think my boss would not
think that's reasonable.
So bring in sort of
third party perspectives
to establish what what's
fair and reasonable.
And lastly, it has to leave
the relationship intact.
So if you have gone
through all of this
and you come to a resolution,
but you hate each other's guts,
that's not going to give you all
those positive benefits that I
talked about at the beginning.
You're not going to have
a stronger relationship.
You're not going to be
happy to come to work.
So it has to make sure that
the relationship stays intact.
And there's a whole
chapter in the book
about how to repair the
relationship after a conflict.
So you might want to
check that out as well.
So how do you get
to that resolution
when you're having
the conversation?
A couple things.
One, be creative.
So rather than saying, I
believe we should do this,
and your counterpart
coming back and saying,
no I think we
should do this, try
to build on each other's ideas.
So if your counterpart throws
out a potential resolution,
say yes, and I think
we could also do this.
Build on it.
Try to create more options.
Even throw out options
that you don't think
will really work,
because that's going
to give you more information
about their interests.
Because if you throw out
something that's completely
whack a doodle,
they're going to say
that would never work because
of this, and this, and this.
And then you get
more information
about what matters to them
and what they care about.
You also want to collaborate.
You cannot just criticize
each other's ideas.
Think about what can
we propose together,
what additional
information do we need?
What other stakeholders do
we need to get interest from?
Work on it together.
You want to make
sure that it feels
like you're on the
right side of the table
together, not on opposite sides.
And then lastly, consider
what you have to offer.
So oftentimes, in a
difficult conversation
we are trying to sort out
what each person can give.
If you're asking
your counterpart
to give up something
really important,
some interest that's that
really matters to them,
consider what you have
to offer in return.
Maybe it's on something
you can help out
on another project
at another time.
Maybe you do you can do
them a favor down the road.
Whatever it is, that's
going to be invoke this sort
of natural law of reciprocity.
They're going to be more
likely to be willing to give
if you've offered something up.
So of course, I'm
talking about this
again as if you have all
the time in the world.
But most of us, in time
pressured organizations,
are dealing with conflicts
that happen very quickly.
Something comes up in a
meeting, something needs
to be decided today, we
need to tell our bosses how
this is going to be resolved.
So I just want to
give you a few points
of what you can do on the fly.
And then I'll take you
some of your questions.
So first, know your type.
Know whether you tend to
seek or whether you avoid.
That's going to give you
really important information
when you start to react
to conflicts that come up.
So if you tend to be an
avoider, and something
happens in a meeting,
you'll recognize,
OK, this is how I always
react in these situations.
I need to watch myself.
Know the four types of
conflict and name them.
Again, you don't have to use
the terms task, process, status.
But really try to
depersonalize what's happening.
Because when someone
disagrees with you,
as I've mentioned, we start
to think that it's unkind,
that person doesn't
respect me, they
don't think I'm
qualified to be here,
they don't think
I'm good at my job.
And if you can really
focus on actually
we're disagreeing over how
to get this project done,
it's going to help take
some of that emotion
and the personality
out of the situation.
Make smart choices
about your option.
don't just default to hashing
it out or doing nothing.
Really think through, OK,
of these four options,
which is the best here.
And be ready to pivot.
If one option's not working,
be willing to move to another.
And of course,
control your emotions.
You want to make sure--
I cannot tell you how many
conversations I've seen
completely go off the rails
because someone starts to raise
their voice or gets
red in the face.
And it just causes so much
tension and discomfort,
the more you can be calm,
cool, and collected,
even if the other person
isn't, the much more
you're going to set that
conversation on a path
to success.
And it does not
matter the content
of the conversation,
the person who
feels in control
of their emotions
is most likely the person is
going to get what they want out
of the situation.
It's what I observe
all the time when
I'm doing coaching
or consulting,
the people who feel
in control and feel
like they're making
rational decisions always
have the upper hand.
So I'm going to
take some questions.
If I leave you with
one thing today,
I really want you
to remember this,
which is that it is your
job to disagree with people.
It is your job to have opinions
that differ from people.
It is what makes work good
and what makes it sort of fun
to be at.
So do not think of
disagreement as unkindness.
It's actually a kind thing to
do if you do it the right way.
So thank you all so
much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: That was really good.
Thank you.
And we'll take questions.
So who has a question.
I'm going to go over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
those kind of frameworks
are really helpful to me.
So I appreciate that.
AMY GALLO: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes
conflict arises
because of the processes
in a large org.
And a portion of that org
feels dismissed or diminished
because of it and those
conflicts happen over time.
I'm curious about
how we translate
these kind of
one-one-one experiences
to those larger kind
of conversations.
AMY GALLO: Yeah, so
a couple of things.
One of which is we all
work in organizations
where we don't have
a ton of control
over things, how things happen.
So what I tell people is
focus on what you can control.
It can be really easy to
think about the larger
cultural issues or the
larger process issues
and really focus on those.
But if you were powerless
to change those,
you're going to feel nothing
but sort of depressed
and have a sort of
a lack of agency.
So really focus on
the interactions
and the human to human.
I think these
frameworks definitely
apply at a larger level though.
So let's say your
department is interacting
with another department that
tends to feel dismissed,
you can really think
about can we really focus
on what the actual conflict is.
If they come in with a
man down kind of attitude,
how do we really
focus on what we're
trying to achieve, not
that interpersonal issue.
Ultimately, at the end
of the day, all of this
gets played out in a one-to-one
or one-to-many interaction.
So really focus on how you
can sort of compensate or undo
some of those myths or some
of those predispositions
in the interaction.
And oftentimes, that
can sort of set--
Annie McKey, who
wrote a great book,
you guys should have
her actually-- called
"How to be Happy at Work" and
she talks about micro cultures.
So we're all subject
to the larger
culture of our organization,
or our department, or our team,
but what she's observed is that
people create micro cultures.
It might just start
with two people,
or it might start with a segment
of a team, where you start
interacting the way you
wish people around you
were interacting.
And it starts to set the
behavior, not necessarily--
sometimes it will impact
the broader organization,
but more importantly,
it just protects you in
that moment, of I have the
safety of this micro culture,
in which I know I can
behave, and live my values,
and be happy at work.
SPEAKER: Great,
another question?
AUDIENCE: I had two questions,
but she asked one of them.
So you took care of
the bigger one, which
was kind of the issue of larger
scales than just two people
having conflict.
The probably easier,
shorter one, question
is, what you described
as a process conflict,
I was hearing more--
not process, I
meant task, what you
described as a task conflict--
I was hearing that more as
difference of objectives,
people having--
is that a fair characteristic?
AMY GALLO: Absolutely,
so it might
be we disagree about
what the goal is,
or it might be we have
goals and they conflict.
Yeah.
And I think those tensions
in an organization
are really good to have.
It's OK when departments
or teams have
different goals that conflict.
It's how you actually
resolve that conflict,
or how you resolve the
misalignment that matters.
And that's the opportunity.
I sometimes say that managers
have a responsibility
to create tensions
on an organization.
If everyone in your
team sees eye to eye
and is really aligned,
you're not doing your job.
People need to bring in
diverse perspectives.
They need to see
things differently.
They need to disagree with
the strategies or the goals,
because that's going to make
the work much more robust.
SPEAKER: Great,
and next question.
AUDIENCE: This might be a little
bit of a difficult question,
but I didn't know if you had any
advice you can give to women,
who there's that existing
societal expectation that we're
supposed to be agreeable.
AMY GALLO: Yeah,
I could do a whole
another talk about the gender
issues around conflict.
There's some great research
about women in negotiation,
and exactly the
societal expectations.
The research was done by
Hannah Riley Bowles, who
is at Harvard Kennedy School.
And it shows that women tend
not to negotiate for themselves,
not because they don't know how
to or don't have the skills,
but because they are
penalized for doing so.
So both men and women who
witness a woman negotiate
are far more likely
to say they don't
want to work with
her than if they
see a man do the same
exact kind of negotiation.
Now I'm a big believer in you
control what you can control.
If I knew how to change
that societal expectation,
I would do that.
That's what I would be
spending my life doing.
But since we cannot
control that,
you have to think a little bit
about how do I deal with that
expectation and that risk,
that if I do negotiate.
The answer is not
to not negotiate.
What Hannah and
also a woman named
Debbie Cole at
Babson advise is what
they call the I-we strategy.
So instead of negotiating
for I, or yourself,
you're negotiation for we.
So how is what you want best
for the organization, or how
is what you want
best for the team.
The classic example Hannah
uses is Sheryl Sandberg, when
she negotiated her salary
with Mark Zuckerberg
said, before the salary
negotiation said, as your COO,
you want me to be
good at negotiation.
So I'm going to show
you right now how good I
am at negotiation.
And she was negotiating
for herself,
but she pitched it as I'm
negotiating on behalf of you.
It's an incredibly
tiresome mental gymnastics
to have to do.
But it's the reality
that we live in.
And I do think that
strategy of how
is this best for
the organization,
how is this best for my team,
that's another way women
tend to get away
with negotiation.
My team really needs this.
Again tiresome, wish we
didn't have to do it.
But it is in an effective
way to get around that.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So during a very tense
moment, what kind of emotions
do you suggest portraying?
AMY GALLO: Well, OK,
that's a difficult--
I actually find that more
difficult than the gender
question.
Partly because what you want
to portray is authentic.
So if you're trying to portray
that you're calm and collected,
and you're actually
fidgeting, that
is much worse than actually
portraying your anger.
Because what people
interpret is a dissonance
between what's happening.
And that dissonance is
so confusing to people.
And it makes things really,
really difficult to actually
have a conversation.
So first and foremost,
portray the authentic emotion
you're having or what you
can truly portray as real.
So you're not communicating
that disagreement
with your body language
and your emotions.
That said, I do think that it's
OK sometimes to express anger
in a disagreement.
I had a colleague who had a
really difficult situation
with a colleague.
She had been really
working hard to stay calm
in these conversations.
Every time he said
something which she thought
was completely off base,
she did the deep breathing,
the anchoring, and she was calm.
And she lost it one
time and yelled.
And he stopped after
the meeting and said,
I never knew that I
was frustrating you.
And I was like, oh, no.
She had spent all this
time remaining calm,
and she had actually
never conveyed to him
that he was driving her crazy.
And so there are
appropriate moments.
The difference between
what she did at that moment
and what most of us tend to
do is that she had control.
So it wasn't a moment where she
felt like, she felt embarrassed
that she had yelled.
She had really
reached a point where
she was like I have no
choice but to yell right now
and to make clear how I feel.
And it was a rational
decision for her to make.
So portray things
that are authentic.
Be willing to portray
negative emotions,
especially if you feel like
your position's not being heard.
For the most part,
being calm is great,
but only if you
genuinely feel it.
AUDIENCE: What about smiling?
What the [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER: The question is
about smiling, what do you do?
AMY GALLO: Is the question,
should you not smile?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
guess, because you said
disagreement is not unkindness.
I'm just wondering if trying to
project more warmth and empathy
through smiling is either
helpful or unhelpful,
because potentially that could
also cause some dissonance.
AMY GALLO: Yes, great, exactly.
And I think that's
a great question.
Because oftentimes when I'm
helping with a mediation,
what I see happen
is people will say--
this happens all the
time, where people
will have framed
their message, they're
ready for the
conversation, and then they
try to spread their discomfort
over like a 2,000 word
monologue to start.
It's like what's happening here.
So they portray I'm not
feeling comfortable with this.
They portray this is going to
be a really tense, difficult
conversation.
What you want, because
disagreement shouldn't
be unkind, what
you want to portray
is I am comfortable
with the situation.
I feel like it's OK to
have this conversation.
Smiling, if you
feel good about it--
sometimes you have to
help people interpret.
We always think we're much
more transparent than we are.
And I say this around
crying, especially.
If you cry at work, people are
going to just think you're sad.
But people cry for
all sorts of reasons.
They cry because they're mad,
they cry or they're frustrated.
So if you're smiling,
or if you're crying,
or if you're doing
something that you
can tell the other person
is not interpreting,
you can say I'm smiling
because I really
feel like this is an
opportunity for us to resolve
this disagreement
in a productive way.
So really narrate why you're
doing what you're doing,
especially if
you're interpreting
a little bit of discomfort.
But in that regard,
yes, smiling is great.
If you can portray
I'm not uncomfortable
with this conversation,
I'm glad we're having it,
that's a great way to set up
the conversation for success.
SPEAKER: Amy, thank you so much.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]